[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'édition
spéciale de tv 78 nous sommes le
vendredi 16 octobre
et voici les titres à partir de samedi
17 octobre
0 heure le couvre feu annoncé par
emmanuel macron des buts de 21h à 6h du
matin interdiction d'être dans la rue
sauf exception pour cela il faudra se
munir d'une attestation comme pendant le
confinement précision et réactions
d'élus professionnels et policiers dans
les yvelines
à ce sujet nous recevrons le maire
divers droite de poissy karl olive pour
parler de l'implication des élus locaux
dans le couvre-feu dans l'actualité
également la brigade cynotechnique des
pompiers des yvelines est en formation à
l'école nationale vétérinaire d'alfort
objectifs que leur chien puisse détecter
locaux vides 19 en son temps les
personnels une première en france
nous recevrons également l'adjudant chef
david oeil et sapeurs pompiers au centre
de secours de plaisir dans le groupe de
reconnaissance et d'intervention en
milieu périlleux le grimp après
l'explosion du port de beyrouth au liban
il est allé sur place retour
d'expérience dans l'actualité emmanuel
macron a annoncé les nouvelles mesures
pour lutter contre la propagation du
coronavirus mercredi dernier gregory
kane aller fait le point sur la
principale annonce le couvre-feu ça y
est le couvre feu débute ce week end en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines dès
samedi
0 heure un couvre feu d'une durée
minimum de quatre semaines et qui sera
effectif de 21h à 6h du matin dans cette
plage horaire vous devrait être
obligatoirement chez vous sauf motif
dérogatoire ses motifs
les voici pour des raisons sanitaires ou
pour se rendre auprès d'un proche
dépendant pour des raisons
professionnelles si vous vous rendez que
vous rentrez de votre lieu de travail
pour un voyage le billet de train ou
d'avion dans ce cas-là fait foi enfin
pour sortir aussi votre animal de
compagnie et pour justifier de cette
sortie le
gouvernement ressort des oubliettes est
la fameuse attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire elle est à remplir elle sera
légèrement différente de celle du
confinement et à l'heure où je vous
parle vendredi 16 heures cette
attestation n'est toujours pas
disponible sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur
le gouvernement a indiqué qu'elles le
seraient dans la journée de samedi
n hésitez donc pas d'ici là et dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi à remplir
cette attestation de manière manuscrite
comme c'était le cas pendant le
confinement chaque contrevenant s'expose
à 135 euros d'amendé
douze mille policiers et gendarmes vont
être en sont répartis pardon sur
l'ensemble du territoire et vont être en
charge du contrôle du respect du
couvre-feu et évidemment du contrôle des
attestations de quoi susciter des
inquiétudes chez les syndicats on écoute
julien le cam secrétaire d'alliance
police nationale dans les yvelines
[Musique]
pour l'instant on a beaucoup
d'interrogations on n'a toujours pas de
de consigne dans les services
mes collègues sont sont très sceptiques
on espère avoir des instructions fermes
cette fois ci est d'arrêter le laxisme
notamment les consignes qu'on a vu lors
du dernier confinement avec des
consignes de ne pas aller dans certains
quartiers difficiles
donc on espère que cette fois ci on aura
des consignes beaucoup plus ferme
le souci c'est que on est dans dans un
créneau horaire c'est là où on a le
moins d'effectifs on n'a que quatre sont
un peu plus de 450 effectifs en brigade
de nuit sur le département ce qui est
très peu parce que si vous enlevez
malheureusement les malades qui seront
forcément touché par aussi le co vide 19
on est sur ce créneau horaire où on a le
moins d'effectifs sur le département et
donc on pense qu'il y aura de nombreux
décalages de fonctionnaires de jour qui
iront renforcer nos collègues de nuit
[Musique]
oui surtout que dans les yvelines il
faut rappeler que lors du dernier
confinement on a eu des périodes de
violences urbaines très violente avec je
vous dis des quartiers ou des collègues
avaient pour instruction de ne pas
intervenir de ne pas aller patrouille et
donc si vous voulez on espère enfin que
le gouvernement donnera des instructions
des moyens mes collègues et que surtout
les tribunaux suivront et émettront des
peines exemplaires aux personnes qui ne
respectent pas le confinement ou qui
s'en prennent à mes collègues durant
cette période le couvre-feu sera t'il
bien respectées on viens de l'entendre
des inquiétudes du syndicat de policiers
alliance
au niveau des mers aussi le doute
subsiste quant à l'application d'une
telle mesure c'est le cas du maire de
trappes à lire à b il est l'invité de
nicolas kirillovitch dans l'hebdo
politique dimanche sur radio sensations
on a vu dans certaines zones qu'on
appelle tendue certains quartiers
difficiles
à la fin du confinement d'aider des
problèmes du fait notamment du du
confinement est ce que vous pensez que
ça va être difficile à appliquer dans
ces zones précisément et peut-être à
trappes de faire respecter ce couvre-feu
entre 21h et 6h ce que vous redoutez ça
vaut ça ne sera pas simple honnêtement
après la période automnale et hivernale
qui arrive
fake de fait les gens sortent moins y'a
moins d'interactions mais le fait de
mettre fin à nos activités à 21h en
réalité un peu plus tôt le couvre-feu à
21h ça veut dire que la dernière
activité sur le rif de trappes c'est à
20h30 par exemple pour vous permettre de
rentrer chez vous mais la fin des
activités sportives des activités
culturelles à 20h32 fait ça limite les
interactions tout le monde rentre chez
soi
y'a plus rien d'ouvert plus de
restaurant + 2 et de fait on aura
beaucoup moins de monde à après est-ce
qu'il n'y aura aucun trappistes dans les
rues de trappes aucun versailles et dans
les rues de versailles à 21h c'est pas
certain
bonsoir et bienvenue karl olive vous
êtes le maire de poissy et vous êtes
avec nous ce soir pour parler de
l'annnonce de ce couvre-feu qui débute
ce week end
est ce que comme la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse
vous pensez que le couvre-feu était la
seule solution possible pour endiguer la
propagation du virus
bonsoir eléonore mais merci pour cette
invitation
écoutez on saura finalement dans quatre
semaines à l'issue du couvre-feu
on est dans un état de frustration au
même titre que lors du confinement est d
aider six semaines de confinement la
vérité c'est que la peur n'évite pas le
danger
et quand on voit aujourd'hui la
propagation du virus il fallait prendre
des décisions qui sont parfois des
décisions des décisions draconiennes
et rappelons que ce n'est pas le virus
qui circule ce sont les hommes et les
femmes qui font circuler le virus
d'accord et est ce que comme certains de
vos collègues maires je cite arnaud
péricard par exemple le maire de saint
germain en laye préféré que le
couvre-feu soit plutôt décalé de 22h à
21,2 21h pardon à 22h écoutez le du coup
on a aussi la réaction pardon de pierre
bédier président du département qui est
lui aussi de cet avis écoutez le au
micro de nicolas quere l'oit pour être
très honnête je trouve
ou que le premier réflexe 1 je ne suis
pas un grand expert mais je pense que si
on avait fait un couvre feu à 22 heures
ça aurait permis de maintenir une
certaine activité dans la restauration
parce que 21h ça me paraît difficile
délicat ça aurait aussi pour les grands
banlieusards que nous sommes facilité de
retour au travail parce qu'il ya des
gens qui rentrent après 21h et qui ça
n'inquiète donc bon je pense qu'il
fallait une mesure de couvre feu
puisqu'il ya manifestement un problème
de relance de l'épidémie est-ce que les
modalités sont sont justes sans doute
fuites ont pu imaginer un autre horaire
est ce que donc vous si vous préférez
que le couvre-feu commence à 22 heures
plus tôt qu'à 21h moi je crois
l'appartement où la décision a été prise
il faut il faut la respecter
évidemment encore une fois c'est un
événement qui va frustrer les
commerçants les restaurateurs
parce que typiquement leurs premiers
services est lui aussi annulé
maintenant oui souillac fois ci se
trouve que j'ai pris une décision à la
mi septembre qui était d'annuler la
d'interdire la vente de l'alcool après
20 heures sur l'espace public notamment
avec les commerces de proximité pourquoi
j'ai cette décision et peut-être que ça
mène aussi à prendre ce type de décision
tout simplement parce qu'on crée des
clusters et qu on s'apercevait qu'à
poissy après 20 heures
un certain nombre de jeunes de moins
jeunes d'ailleurs se retrouver sur la
place publique
après la scène pour profiter du grand
air
depuis j'ai pris cette décision il ya
parfois moins de rassemblements alors
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué pour les
restaurateurs
on aurait tous aimé ce soit même 22
heures on aurait tous aimé aussi j'ai
pensé pour att venir eléonore notamment
sur les événements culturels mon ma
programmation de théâtre il ya dix jours
où nous recevions east of the valley y
avait mille personnes ça s'est très bien
passé
or du masque obligatoire un respect de
toutes les gestes barrières et pourtant
aujourd'hui va falloir avancer
effectivement ces événements peut-être
les décaler le dimanche on appelle en
matinée et en après-midi les
intermittents du spectacle faut penser
aussi à eux ça va être très compliqué
pour ce type de deux corporations
maintenant je m'aperçois que la france
n'est pas un micro tribun ce qui se
passe en france s'est passé en allemagne
et que en france aujourd'hui on a 800
mille cas désigné il y en a 400 milles
depuis le début d'épidémie en allemagne
et on voit bien qu'il se passe quand
même quelque chose au travers du monde
l'espagne a confiné le canada confirme
la nouvelle zélande a confiné également
donc il fallait des mesures qui soient
des mesures draconiennes et encore une
fois
croisons les doigts pour que d'ici
quatre semaines est bien de puissions
reprendre une vie entre guillemets
normal donc pour vous c'est non pas à
22h vient 21h on reste comme ça coûtait
jusqu'à preuve du contraire le président
de la république
cette décision et je ne suis pas de
certains pour avoir eu mes services du
ministère de la culture que cette
décision soit malheureusement contre
indiquée sur un autre sujet donc
toujours sur ce couvre-feu est ce que
les mères vous qui vont être chargés du
coup de faire respecter ce fameux
couvre-feu en ont les moyens est ce que
le ministre de l'intérieur doit mettre à
votre disposition des forces
supplémentaires ou est-ce que avec votre
police municipale ça va faire le job
alors moi très honnêtement ma police
municipale mais 44 agents de police
municipale qui font un travail
remarquable ont pas vocation à se
retrouver derrière chacun des habitants
pour voir si après 21h il est rentré à
la maison il a terminé son dîner moi je
remercie l'omjs de l'intérieur de mettre
à disposition des forces supplémentaires
parce que dans les priorisation qui sont
les miennes moi je préfère que mes
policiers municipaux je sois vraiment
affectée à la lutte des incivilités au
quotidien on avait une opération pour
chasser les poids lourds en transit on
avait aussi des problèmes d'incivilité
de délire dans les quartiers la place de
ma police municipale elle est là elle
est vraiment pour respecter ce plan de
prévention des risques urbains
ça va être très compliqué c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'il faut aussi
responsabiliser les français
encore une fois c'est pas des décisions
qui sont prises par québec heure c'est
simplement de la responsabilisation pour
reculer lui d'épidémie un virus qui tue
des vies 10h31 mille âmes qui sont
partis depuis le début de l'épidémie
et justement toujours sujet de la
sécurité et de la des forces de l'ordre
vous plaider pour un renforcement du
pouvoir des maires en matière de
sécurité justement ne serait ce pas le
moment d'en parler
écoutez j'ai ça fait déjà quelques
années que j'en parle c'est pas pour
rien si on a mis en place un plan de
prévention des risques urbains
encore une fois fois ci pas depuis trois
semaines a depuis depuis 2000 pièces
donc ça fait plus de cinq ans oui moi je
souhaite que le pouvoir des maires soit
élargi typiquement hier ont fait une
opération pour contrôler des poils au
qui n'ont rien à faire à possible de les
arrêter pour le non-respect des plus de
trois tonnes 5
il ya trois centres 15 % des contrôles
qui ont eu lieu hier voix qui démontre
que les l'épaule ou renie rien à faire
dans la ville entre les verbalise
aujourd'hui la la la la bande est à 35
euros minorée à 22 euros c'est cette
personne l'épais dans les trois jours
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on élargisse
le pouvoir et que ce pouvoir passe à 400
euros
là ce sera dissuasif de la même manière
que ici sur la place publique
quand je vais grâce aux caméras de vidéo
protection interne interpellé un
individu en flagrant délit de de
graffitis par exemple ou deux vols à
l'étalagé qu'on puisse tout de suite et
réagir et tout de suite le verbaliser ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
il faut interpeller l'individu lors
néopolis à la police nationale porté
plainte et ensuite c'est la justice qui
prend le relais la vérité c'est qu'on
souhaite
le snui et j'ose espérer que gérald
amman avec lequel j'ai des jaunes et je
me suis entretenu sur le sujet a eu
notre chance
dernière question vous avez publié un
tweet très favorable au report des
élections départementales et régionales
le président a justement annoncé qu'une
commission serait créée avec l'ensemble
des partis pour évoquer ce sujet et
notamment ce report
que répondez-vous un petit peu à ceux
qui disent que ce report apparaît comme
une manoeuvre politique pour repousser
des élections alors moi je vais très
clair le report des élections
départementales et régionales
je le réclame déjà depuis plus d'un an
et non seulement je réclame ce record
mais je réclame également sa déconnexion
pourquoi d'abord parce qu'on voit bien
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui si on veut
réitérer cette abstention record aux
dernières municipales
alors allons-y premièrement deuxièmement
on aura le jour même si c'est toujours
maintenu deux élections totalement
différente avec le scrutin différent
une élection au scrutin uninominal
les départementales est plutôt de
proximité une élection régionale au
scrutin 10 et plus tôt et national enfin
elle dernière dernier élément deux
élections le jour même c'est plus de 200
personnes mobilisées ici apprécie ces
deux bureaux dans le même dans la même
dans la même salle pour les deux
élections et je dirais que c'est le
virus circule encore un petit peu plus
ce serait pour moi de bon aloi
aujourd'hui de pouvoir décaler sélection
on a eu une annonce avec le report du
salon de l'agriculture qui a lieu une
semaine auparavant
comment ses compagnes dans ces
conditions c'est juste pas d'accord et
bien très bien merci karl olive d'avoir
été avec nous pour cette 8e édition
spéciale il avait échappé aux mesures
prises au mois de septembre
les restaurateurs heavy noah joue de
cette fois largement être touchée par
les nouvelles mesures
réaction de la profession avec astrid
bergère et patrick jacques de dixmude
coup dur pour les restaurateurs qui
était déjà en difficulté
il sera interdit de circuler après 21h
dans les yvelines à partir de samedi au
lendemain des annonces de nombreuses
interrogations occupe les esprits
ça va être compliqué moi ça on verra on
verra pas qu'à partir de de la semaine
prochaine comment sans mal géré et
comment seront les gens s'ils seront
toujours présents déjà d'une part et et
comment on les enlève
comment ils partiront une fermeture à
21h qui aura des conséquences sur la
gestion du personnel
puisqu'on va perdre quatre heures le
soir donc évidemment il y aura des gens
au chômage partiel à juziers dans ce
restaurant les clients viennent
d'habitude vers 20h30
cette fois pas le choix il faudra
adapter le service du soir on va
commencer à partir 18 heures alors est
ce qu'il va voir du monde ou pas je suis
pas convaincu mais voilà de 18h jusqu'à
20h on va dire jusqu'à 20h pouvoir
prendre des tables dernière table à 20
heures le temps que les gens puissent
puissent manger et tout et qu'en gros à
20h45
20h50 que le service soit terminée quoi
les propriétaires de l'atelier de gaëtan
ont perdu presque cent mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires cette année une perte
considérable pour une petite structure
comme celle ci ce qui correspond à nos
trois mois de fermeture plus une grosse
partie traiteur que nous avons aussi en
moins parce que sur l'événementiel en ce
moment nous n'avons quasiment plus rien
les restaurants qui comptent moins de 50
salariés pourront compter sur le fonds
de solidarité à partir de 50 % de perte
de chiffre d'affaires l'aide pourra
aller jusqu'à dix mille euros
le monde de la culture est lui aussi
impacté par les annonces du chef de
l'état un nouveau coup de massue pour
les salles de spectacles cinéma qui
commençait timidement à reprendre
pour l'heure les acteurs culturels
locaux entendent se mobiliser pour
maintenir une offre est resté ouvert
entre adaptation des horaires et reports
c'est un vrai casse tête pour les salles
de spectacle et cinéma ils n'ont eu en
plus que 48 heures pour réagir
l'exemple du théâtre coluche à plaisir
avec la directrice florence k - là la
saison en cours celle qui vient de
commencer en septembre
tout aura lieu s'il faut reporter on
reportera mais les gens pourront voir
tous les spectacles qu'on a proposé on
en aura pas d'autres temps que ceux là
n'auront pas été là pour l'instant les
consignes du gouvernement c'est celle
simplement couvre-feu à 21h on jouera
plus tôt et je suis sûr que les gens
vont venir et qu'ils seront très content
de pouvoir continuer à venir au théâtre
même un peu plus tôt dans la soirée
anne hidalgo maire de paris et roselyne
bachelot mist ministre de la culture
plaidait pour une dérogation qui
permettait de quitter les salles de
spectacles et de cinéma à 21h vendredi
le premier ministre jean castex a
déclaré qu'il n'y était pas favorable
c'est une première en france des chiens
pour détecter le qu'ovide 19
c'est le projet du professeur dominique
grandjean de l'école nationale
vétérinaire d'alfort et pour y parvenir
les pompiers de la brigade cynotechnique
des yvelines sont formés depuis
plusieurs semaines immersion dans une
formation un peu particulière il
s'appelle orties osca oxmo leiko ou
encore jim qu ils seront bientôt des
chiens détecteurs de co vite 19 d'ici
deux semaines
ils auront terminé leur formation à
l'école nationale vétérinaire d'alfort
tout comme leurs maîtres pompiers de la
brigade cynotechnique des yvelines
initialement ces pompiers et leurs
chiens sont spécialisés dans la
recherche de personnes égarées ou de
personnes ensevelies
l'objectif de ce nouvel apprentissage
détecter le coronavirus en reniflant on
apprend aux chiens à mettre le nez dans
l'économie actifs dans ces cônes
olfactif
on va mettre des prélèvements de sueur
axillaires donc c'est à dire bien sûr
sous les aisselles dans les cônes de
telle façon à ce que les chiens puissent
définir c'est un problème on positif ou
négatif
cette formation intervient dans le cadre
du programme noah this dirigée par le
professeur dominique grandjean et en
collaboration avec l'université saint
joseph de beyrouth au liban
créé il ya deux ans avec son équipe le
professeur travailler avec les chiens
sur la détection médical notamment du
cancer du côlon aujourd'hui avec la
crise sanitaire
son programme a pris une autre tournure
donc je me souviens début mars en
réunion dans mon bureau et ryad sarkis
qui est professeur à l'université de
beyrouth et le team de julien makemo la
coordinatrice en fait du programme de
naïs bas ils m'ont poussé dans mes
derniers retranchements 10 on devra
essayer en dresser on a essayé c'est le
démarrage de ce que j'appelle laventure
chien que vite parce que depuis ça a
pris une ampleur à l'international
surtout j'ai quand même assez
extraordinaire
cette formation est donc une première en
france mais aussi une première pour les
chiens des pompiers yvelinois il a
forcément fallu un petit temps
d'adaptation on a l'habitude d'avoir des
chiens qui sont libres sont contraintes
à courir il ya un petit peu partout bien
sûr sous notre contrôle
et là on leur demande de mettre le nez
dans les cônes c'est quelque chose de
très très près si deux très contraignant
pour eux pour avoir ce qu'ils font
d'habitude donc au début c'est vrai que
c'était un petit peu
on va dire excité même si c'est pas
vraiment le terme exact
ils se sont vraiment tous posé les
chiens devraient bientôt être
opérationnels cela permettrait à terme
de diminuer les tests pcr effectués sur
les pompiers yvelinois bonsoir et
bienvenue adjudant chef david oeil et
vous êtes pompiers professionnels aux 10
78 affecté au centre de secours de
plaisir vous faites partie également du
groupe de reconnaissance et
d'intervention en milieu périlleux alors
on appelle ça le grimp
c'est ça vous êtes avec nous aujourd'hui
pour parler de votre intervention suite
aux explosions dans le port de beyrouth
au liban le 4 août dernier
des explosions faisant plus de 190 morts
et des milliers de blessés
également plus de 85 mille locaux ont
été endommagés vous êtes arrivés sur
place vous le 24 août
d'abord qu'elle a été un petit peu votre
sentiment en arrivant sur place
alors bien sûr place et on a vu ce qui
s'était passé à la télé et c'est vrai
qu'une fois sur place on comprend
vraiment lent qu'on voit vraiment
l'ampleur des dégâts on se dit bon il ya
beaucoup de billets beaucoup de travail
et on sait pas trop par où on va
commencer quoi alors sachant que proche
du proche du sinistre tout est détruit
il reste vraiment plus rien donc nous on
s'est vraiment focalisé sur les
quartiers vraiment touchée où il ya les
habitations quoi essentiellement et quel
est votre rôle du coup un temps complet
du grimp
dans une intervention telle que celle ci
alors nous nouons notre champ
d'application au groupe c on intervient
à la base là où les moyens traditionnels
des sapeurs-pompiers sont limitées et où
les moyens aériens ne peuvent pas
accéder donc nous c'est long c'est là
qu'on intervient sur les opérations
diverses et les évacuations des victimes
donc là vraiment au liban on était
vraiment dans le cadre d'opérations
diverses sur ceux sur ses bâtiments et
vous êtes parti combien de temps vous
êtes resté combien de temps sur nous
sommes restés deux jours 12 jours
d'accord et comment ça s'est passé
qu'est ce qu'elle est un petit peu
l'émission précise que vous
devis effectuées sur place alors la
première des missions et ça c'était
vraiment un travail qu'on a eue avec la
municipalité de beyrouth et les
architectes
on a priorisé et la première c'était de
remettant sur en service les lits
surface de l'hôpital saint-georges de
beyrouth
très rapidement parce que l'hélicoptère
de l'armée libanaise l'utilisent au
quotidien
donc c'était l'une des priorités et puis
après c'était d'intervenir sur les les
bâtiments d'habitation
vous êtes affecté dans les yvelines au
centre de secours de plaisir cela vous
arrive souvent de partir à l'étranger
comme ça pour une intervention
alors là c'était vraiment une première
et notamment pour le grimp parce qu'il
est toujours associé ou un dispositif et
notamment avec le sauvetage déblaiement
en intervient essentiellement surtout en
france lors des catastrophes donc les
tempêtes comme celle de 99 ou là les
récents coups de vent qu'on a pu avoir
merci pour ces précisions adjudant chef
david douillet est d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui pour cette édition spéciale
une dernière actualité avant de refermer
justement cette édition spéciale une
marche vers l'elysée
à l'appel de collectifs et
d'associations des sciences à papier
pardon se mobilisent ils sont partis de
plusieurs grandes villes de france avec
pour but d'arriver à paris pour une
grande manifestation samedi 17 octobre
répartis par région les sans papiers du
grand ouest sont partis jeudi 15 octobre
de versailles et sont allés jusqu'à
plaisir là où se trouve le centre de
rétention administrative des yvelines
ils ont expliqué leurs revendications à
patrick jacques de dixmude la
régularisation sans exception de tous
les sans papiers dans toute l'étendue du
territoire national
la fermeture des centres de rétention
administrative et un logement pour tout
et pour tout c'est ça les trois points
de revendications et nous avons aussi
une lettre à le à le lire à mes yeux
marrons et
en sachant que celle là était dirigée
par tout l'ensemble des collectifs de
soutien aux sans-papiers qui participent
à cette marche c'est d'abord une
affirmation de l'existence de toutes ces
personnes qui sont là ils vivent avec
nous qui vivent au milieu de nous qui
travaillent qui essayent de survivre de
faire vivre leur famille et donc c'est
déjà quelque chose qui soit visible
qu'on comprenne les difficultés qui sont
les leurs le parcours final de la place
de la république à jusqu'à la concorde à
paris avait été déposée il y a des
semaines pour cette manifestation
mais le préfet de police a notifié mardi
dernier un arrêté pour l'interdire c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission spéciale
merci de l'avoir suivi l'information
revient lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal
présenté par grégory canal et d'ici là
vous pourrez nous retrouver sur notre
site internet tv 78 points comme ou bien
sur notre application mobile tv 78 et je
vous souhaite un très bon week-end et
une très belle soirée
[Musique]